Das Podcast UFO. Das Podcast UFO. UFO, UFO. So, danke. Herzlich willkommen zu das Podcast UFO, Folge 135, heute ist Montag. Schön. Weiß ich nicht. Man lernt beim Radio, lernt man eigentlich, wie man bedürftige Anmoderationen macht, nämlich mit Datum, mit einem Hallo, mit einem Wer sind wir, aber wir haben das erste Mal was Intro viel zu lang, dann ist unser Datum scheißegal, weil wir wahrscheinlich erst viel später veröffentlicht werden. Und man muss sich eigentlich auch noch mal fünftig vorstellen. Mein Name ist Stefan Dietze und das ist Florentin Willen. Schön, dass ihr da seid heute. Herzlich willkommen, das war die Anmoderation. Ich will direkt zur ersten Rubrik übergehen, nämlich Podcast-UFO-Feedback. Oder ein anderer, besserer Name für diese Rubrik ist Podcast-UFO-Hate. Hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate, hate Podcast-Ufo der einzige Podcast wäre, dem Stefan Thiel zu seiner butterweiche Stimme leist. Was ist das jetzt hier? Es kommt so ein Rant. Ich habe Bock auf die Folge, oder was? Und du kommst direkt in den Raum und machst mich hier fertig. Es kam auch kein Hallo von dir, du hast ja einfach in deinem Mikrofon gesetzt, Kopfüber aufgesetzt. Schön, dass du darauf aufmerksam gemacht hast, denn das ist genau die Attitüde, die ich ansprechen will. Genau dieses, andere Leute sollen mir zuspielen, es geht mir nämlich um die letzte Folge Antenne Alderaan. Antenne Alderaan, May the Fourth. Ich will die nicht thematisieren. Leg die Zeitung weg. Du kannst dich nebenbei Zeitung lesen. Aber das ist eigentlich so ein Moment, wo man die Zeitung weglegt und dann zuhört, weil das Thema plötzlich ernst wird am Tisch.
Was? Moment. Ja, stimmt. Das war so früher der Mic Drop. Na, das ist das Gegenteil von Mic Drop. Was habe ich gesagt? Es ging im letzten Antenne-Aldaran-Stefans-Tolben-Star-Wars-Podcast um eine tolle Szene, die sein Co-Moderator Simon, Timo, Timo, ausgegraben hat. Einen Schritt. Du bist immer einen Schritt. Simon, Timon.
Ihr habt ja so eine fantastische Rubrik ausgegraben, wo Timo ausgegraben hat. Einen Schritt, du bist immer einen Schritt. Simon, Timon.
Ihr habt ja so eine fantastische Rubrik ausgegraben,
wo Timo immer so ein paar Zitate,
ein paar Clips, ein paar Gags aus vergangener Zeit rausholt.
Und da hat er was ganz Tolles gefunden.
Und zwar, es war ja am 4. Mai, May the 4th,
so für alles da, wo es Freak ist da draußen.
Und da hat er einen Clip rausgegraben,
das finde ich immer toll von ihm, aus TV Total. Ja, okay, demnächst kommt der große Rant gegen LaCast. Aus TV Total hat er einen Clip rausgeschnitten, und zwar als irgendwo zu einem großen Anlass, ich glaube zu Star Wars Episode I oder so was, George Lucas auf einer Pressekonferenz interviewt wurde. Und die Pressekonferenz wurde synchron gedolmetscht und alles, was gesagt wurde, wurde übersetzt auf Deutsch. Und am Ende der Pressekonferenz wurde George Lucas gefragt, wollen Sie denn nochmal das legendäre, grosse Star Wars Zitat, das jeder so gerne hört und jeder gerne kennt, wollen Sie das nochmal sagen, Herr Lucas? Und Lucas hat das Zitat gesagt, May the fourth be with you, aber anscheinend kannte der Übersetzer kein Star Wars und kannte das Zitat nicht und hat dann on the fly übersetzt, was er gehört hat und er hat übersetzt, am 4. Mai werde ich bei euch sein. Und als ich das im Podcast, ich war im Rewe, als ich den Podcast hatte, ich hatte den Drang, mich auf den Boden zu legen, weil ich so hart lachen musste. Allein die Vorstellung, Kopf dieses Übersetzers, das in dieser multimillionenschweren, unfassbar beliebten Science-Fiction-Saga das Zitat, mit dem man eine Pressekonferenz beendet, lautet Am 4. Mai werde ich bei euch sein. Das ist das legendäre Star Wars Zitat. Das fand ich so, ich habe wirklich die Leute angelacht, ich habe ihnen ins Gesicht gelacht, reingelacht. Und weißt du, wie Stefan Tietze reagiert hat? Nichts, gar nichts, nichts, kein Lacher, kein Wort, wie lustig ist das denn, wo ich mir dachte, was ist denn jetzt mit dir los? Man muss ja sagen, im Antenne-Alldach ist Stefan ja ein anderer Mensch, da ist er ja, oh, Fakten, Fakten. Ich fand das unglaublich lustig, aber kennst du das nicht? Es ist unfassbar lustig. Ja, auf jeden Fall, aber manchmal muss man doch lachen, manchmal muss man einfach, ist es zu lustig, um lachen zu müssen. Ich finde diese Geschichte auch unglaublich lustig. War das der Moment, wo es zu lustig war, um lachen zu müssen? Ich glaube schon, augenscheinlich. Also ich habe auch in Erinnerung, dass ich sehr darüber gelacht habe,
aber vielleicht habe ich nicht darüber gelacht. Ich meine, ich stehe
ja sonst relativ selten Anekdoten aus dem
Antenne-Alderan-Podcast, aber ich dachte,
diese Anekdote hat nicht genug
Lacher bekommen, deswegen muss ich
sie hier nochmal rauszerren und muss nochmal
eine ganz heftige Feedback-Welle.
Und muss hier in dieser Kirche, in der wir uns heute
befinden, vor der gesamten Gemeinde
die bis jetzt noch recht ruhig geblieben ist, um das mal zu sagen. Clara, ich schau dich an! Am besten in der Kirche fand ich immer, dass dann die Zahl eingeblendet wurde, das Lied, das man jetzt singt. Was ein geniales System. Und davor, was ist davor passiert? Da haben die irgendwas gesungen. Ja, nur dieses eine Lied, was alle kanntennten. Glaubst du, sind so diese Kanons entstanden, dass Leute einfach unterschiedliche Songs gesungen haben? Ich glaube, die sind so entstanden, dass diese Einblendung oft zu spät kam. Und dass man erst ganz spät, ab der zweiten Strophe erst dann die Seite aufgeschlagen hat und hat dann mitgesungen, zu der Melodie, die eigentlich aber schon die zweite Strophe eigentlich sein soll. Aber war nicht früher nicht auch langsamer, dass das irgendwie lange gedauert hat, bis es in den letzten Reihen war? Richtig. Aber ich finde das gut von dir. Also offensichtlich hat das nicht genug Aufmerksamkeit bekommen, diese Anekdote. Und deswegen vielen, vielen Dank. Das war die Gag-Nothilfe. Gerne. Und wir müssen, das mache ich auch manchmal, dass ich Gags von mir nochmal benutze aus alten Folgen, nicht weil mein Repertoire vorbei ist
oder ich ein dusseliges Gedächtnis habe.
Nein, die haben dann einfach in meinen Augen zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit bekommen.
Ja. Und ja.
Ich finde das großartig.
Ich kann den ... Ich schaff's nicht.
Ich kann den X-Wing nicht aus dem Sumpf heben.
Am 4. Mai bei euch sein, ich werde da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da Was soll das sein? Es stimmt. Es gibt so eine Regel, dass du in Science-Fiction-Filmen, um diese neue Welt klarzumachen, darfst du zum Beispiel keine Knöpfe benutzen. Okay. Also das ist ein Trick für Kostümbildner. Also Knallungsknöpfe. Genau. Also Kostümbildner bei Science-Fiction-Filmen haben die Regel sich selber auferlegt, keine Knöpfe, weil Knöpfe immer sofort nach Erde aussehen. Weil es unterbewusst werden auch, aber ich verstehe es total, weil es wirkt total wie etwas, naja, was auf der Erde einzigartig sein könnte. Wo man irgendwo im Star-Wars-Film Knöpfe sieht, würde ich sagen, ja, weird. Was ist mit Klettverschluss? Alles ist mit Klettverschlüssen oder Reissschüssen geregelt. Das akzeptiert man. Aber keine fucking Knöpfe. Sie greifen an, rüstet euch ausleuten. Macht einfach die coolen Szenen nicht so cool. Alles voll auch lederig, alles wackelt die ganze Zeit. Wir müssen uns anschleichen. Aber das finde ich geil. Und genauso wenig hört man auch von Montag, Dienstag. Ja, total. Kannst du nächste Woche Mittwoch noch mal vorbeikommen, Hanson, dann habe ich vielleicht dein Millennium Falcon fertig repariert. So um zwölf rum an der alten Mühle. Hört man selten, muss man echt sagen. Aber gibt es denn Wochentage in Star Wars? Nee, das Einzige, was man mitbekommt, ist, dass Luke sagt, wobei Onkel Oden sagt doch zu ihm, die nächste Saison, mach doch die nächste Saison für mich und dann kannst du gehen. Das ist auch schon so ein bisschen grenzwertig, nächste Saison. Es gibt jetzt auch diesen neuen Film, diesen Solo, wo ich mich immer frage, gibt es Menschen, die diese Filme mögen? Und zwar rede ich von Mittelalter auf die Fresse Actionfilmen. Das hat vielleicht mit 300 angefangen, aber jetzt kommt Robin Hood. Robin Hood, aber jetzt nicht halt so, wie man ihn kennt, irgendwie der Held in Strumpfhosen in Nottingham Forest, sondern halt wirklich so. Warst du auch in Isle of Dogs? Nein. Ich dachte, weil der Trailer kam direkt davor. Ach so, den Trailer habe ich auf YouTube gesehen. Und der weirdeste Trailer, weil es ist ja dann oft so, man kann ja da oft mit so einer mittelalterlichen Mentalität hingehen und das alles auseinander pflücken, der Film sagt dir von der ersten Sekunde an Bullshit, das ist alles Bullshit. I don't care. I don't care. Dieser Bogen macht, wenn Leute hintereinander stehen, sterben die alle, weil der Pfeil durch die alle durchgeht. Vor allem, ich denke mir, es ist ein bisschen faul, weißt du, wenn du einen mittelalter Actionfilm machst, dann hast du Bilder im Kopf, wo du sagst, okay, cool, der kann ganz schnell Bogen schießen, der kann im Flug schießen, gebe ich dir alles recht, aber die Visualitäten dieses Films bestehen zu 80% aus Explosionen. Was im Mittelalter explodiert denn? Das ist ja genau das, was du nicht siehst. Genau, vor allem in dem Film, wo es darum geht, dass jemand einen Bogen hat, weil er keine Schusswaffen hat. Deswegen hat er ja einen Bogen. Wenn es alles andere gibt, warum hat er dann einen Bogen? Vor allem, und dann gibt es, glaube ich, auch so eine Art Granatwerfer. Tschüss, Papa. So eine Art Granatwerfer, wo jemand so eine Granate mit der Armbrust schießt, wo ich mir auch denke, warum macht man überhaupt einen Film in dem Mittelalter-Setting, wenn du am Ende sagst, ja, mein Gran Raffer werden schon geil. Gut Leute, wir können auch gehen, wir können auch das in der Zukunft spielen lassen.
Nee, schon Robin Hood, weil der Name ist es so.
Robin Hood, vor allem vielleicht merkt Robin Hood am Ende des Films, diese Armbrust, die hat schon noch ein bisschen mehr Pfeffer.
Also da ist noch ein bisschen mehr hinter.
Das wäre mal ein Story-Ark. Von Burgen auf Armbrust. Da würde ich 90 Minuten lang gebannt auf die Leinwand stieren.
Ja, tatsächlich. Es ist die unemotionalste Story-Ark aller Zeiten, aber ich würde es mir auch angucken. Und am Ende hat er eine Pistole. Der Film dauert zu lange. Aber auch mit so einem Schalldämpfer vorne. Er macht vorne einfach, was habt ihr gesagt, ihr reichen Menschen, denen ich jetzt das Geld abnehmen werde, wie, was hast du gesagt, Schalldämpfer drauf? Ey Leute, der Film dauert schon zu lange, die sind im 17. Jahrhundert, wir müssen irgendwie weitermachen. Aber auch Jamie Fox spielt in dem Film mit und trägt einfach ein T-Shirt. Einfach so, Blok-Bullshit, einfach ein T-Shirt, so völlig egal dann. Das respektiere ich dann auch wieder, wo man ganz klar sieht, da ist es alles egal. Ich dachte, es wollte etwas anderes hinaus, weil ich habe noch keine schwarzen T-Shirts tragen sehen. Bei meinen alten Was ist was Büchern, das kann man eh sagen, was ist was, wohl eher white is white, also da ist wenig. Wow, Stefan Woke, Stefan Woke. Am I right, white is, holy crap, wohl eher white is white, holy This is America, oder was, Stefan? Alter, da ist jemand aufgewacht! Ist das das neue Image von Stefan? Stefan Woke-Tieze? Hast du in der Zeitung gelesen? Das ist ja meine beste Witze. Heute ist meine Printausgabe, oder was? Hast du Bock? Ja, ich habe diese Zeitung vor mir liegen, weil wir in einem anderen Raum sind, mal wieder, again. Und ich finde einfach dieses Geräusch, das fand ich immer schon... Ich konnte Zeitungen nie lesen. Während der Frank-Elster-Masterclass mussten wir ja Zeitungen lesen. Und da habe ich dann immer die Zeit gelesen. Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, warum? Weil es ja eine Journalistenausbildung war auch zuerst. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Axel Springer Akademie. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, bin ich clever, ich lese eine Wochenzeitung wie die Zeit, dann muss ich nur einmal in der Woche lesen. Aber unmöglich zu lesen, ich habe es bis heute nicht hinbekommen, die zu lesen, die als so ein kleines Reklambooklet. Wenn es die Zeit als kleines Reklambooklet gäbe, easy, jetzt habe ich es als E-Book. Das ist wahrscheinlich aber aus Kostengründen, weil Zeitungen müssen ja billig sein. Fun fact, das E-Book von der Zeit ist auch einfach ein dickeres iPad, weil da muss halt schon viel drauf. Ihr merkt, die gesellschaftskritische Ausgabe heute. Aber gab es Schwarze im Mittelalter? Naja, glaub nicht. Das fand ich schon bei Les Miserables. Schwierig. Da gab's ja diesen... Ja, ich bin dagegen, schwarze zu casten. Offensichtlich. Es gab ja Morgan Freeman. Den gab's schon. Ja klar. Das ist schon klar. Und ich mein, Shakespeare hatte ja auch zum Beispiel schwarze Rollen. Othello zum Beispiel war schwarz. Othello? Ja. Wie, Othello und Mobilcom und alle waren dabei? Es ist nicht meine Schuld, dass die Kunstwerke von Shakespeare jetzt als Mobilanbieter missbraucht werden. Blau.de? Bei Blau.de hat er sich verrannt. Ja, ist gut. Das ist dem Monatv. Das ist nicht Shakespeare. Naja, vor allem, weißt du, was mich richtig nervös macht? Wir sind in einem Raum, in dem so Snacks liegen, und zwar liegen da Schokobons aus, und mich irritiert nicht, dass ich die essen will, sondern dass es warm ist. Oh, es ist wirklich warm. Allein die Tatsache, also ich hab, ist es nicht so, dass es mir das Essen jetzt versaut, weil ich will sie gar nicht essen, aber allein die Tatsache, dass weiche Schokolade im Raum ist, macht mich völlig wahnsinnig. Also dieses, ich weiss, Schokolade, das ist eine Gönnung für mich einfach so, da gönne ich mir was, das feiere ich und deswegen ist es immer ein Highlight des Tages. Schokolade, weißt du, ist eine Gönnung. Weißt du, Alter, ist eine Gönnung. Ey, wie kann man es sich nur so hart gönönnen eigentlich, Schokoball? Und wenn es dann weich ist, dann sage ich, mua mua, dann habe ich da keinen Bock drauf. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber Flüssigkeiten im Dunkeln machen mich wahnsinnig. Ich komme darauf, weil du gerade von flüssiger Schokolade sprichst, und mir ist nämlich im Kino aufgefallen, dass ich eine Joghurette noch in meiner Jackentasche hatte. Und dann ist die geschmolzen. Eine Shemorette. Und du hast halt aber erst, vergisst du ja, dass du eine Joghurette in deiner Jackentasche hast. Was man nicht vergessen sollte, weil man immer eine Joghurette als Reserve in der Jackentasche haben sollte. Das ist wie so der letzte Schuss von Jack Sparrow. Man sollte ja immer eine Joghurette in der Jackentasche haben. Und dann habe ich die vergessen und dann ist es ausgelaufen, weil es zu warm wurde. Und dieser Moment, wenn du im Dunkeln bist, irgendwo im Kino oder nachts im Bett, sobald du eine Flüssigkeit berührst, setzen so Urinstinkte ein. So, what könnte Blut sein? Es könnte jetzt Blut sein. Und direkt hat man so eine Panik und dann war der ganze Film für mich ruiniert. Aber das habe ich mal auch nachts, wenn man irgendwo Flüssigkeit spürt, ist es immer schlecht. Wenn man mal Wasser getrunken hat im Bett und dann plampert man und dann, wenn es dunkel ist, es nicht lütt. Flüssigkeit ist immer ein schlechtes Zeichen. Ich war mal in der Wahl Campen und dann ist meine Kabine, der Regen war so clever, hat sich so effektiv in das Zelt geschlängelt, dass meine Kabine voller Wasser gelaufen ist, bis der
Meeresspiegel irgendwann so hoch war, dass er über meiner
Luftmatratze war und du schläfst halt,
denkst dir nicht, wachst plötzlich auf und
bist wie mit einer Luftmatratze
auf hoher See in deiner Kabine
und dann hast du erstmal Probleme. War dann Gott sei Dank doch Blut.
Ja,
aber zum Glück hatte ich mein Kuscheltier dabei, der hat
alles aufgesaugt.
Vollgesaugen,
so ein Riesenteddy. Ich weiß nicht, was mehr Angst machen würde. Aber es gibt jetzt einen Trick, den ich auch ruiert finde. Bei Zelten habe ich mit Fahrtfindern gelernt. Das Erste, was du lernst, wenn du dein Zelt beziehst, ist, wenn es regnet, nicht die Zeltwand berühren. Ja. Weil dann sickert es durch. Why? Warum? Ich verstehe dich überhaupt nicht.
Ja, ich glaube, weil du es dann rausziehst,
also weil du, so weit du dagegen kommst und dann die Hand zurücknimmst,
ziehst du ja einen Tropfen mit,
oder? Ja, aber es ist ja ein Stromkreis.
Also das Wasser läuft ja so lange
runter, weil es keinen
anderen Kreis bilden kann. Genau, und wenn du es erdest?
Ja, das ist genau wie wenn ein Vogel kann sich ja auf eine
Stromleitung setzen, weil der Vogel führt ja nirgendwo hin. Aber wenn der Vogel jetzt mit einem Bein auf dem Boden stehen würde, mit anderen Beinen auf dem Stromkabel, ist tot. Vogeltot. Aber nicht, wenn er oben drauf sitzt. Der erste Vogel, der die Eier hatte, sich auf eine Stromleitung zu setzen. What? Alle so, Gary, nein! Er wollte sich umbringen, aber dann hat er doch ein Held. Ich habe so ein irrationales Bedürfnis, Hochleitungsspannungen zerschneiden zu wollen. Ich denke mir immer, die gehen ja quer durch Deutschland. Weg mit der Spannung, denkst du dir? Die gehen ja quer durch Deutschland. Und da gibt es doch bestimmt auch irgendein Dorf, irgendein kleines verschlafenes Dorf, wo halt irgendwie so Baller-Hochspannungsleitungen, die halt Millionenstädte versorgen, vorbeilaufen, wo ich mir denke, so als gelangweiltes Kind, so als Prankster-Kind.
Ja. Da mal mit einer Schere hoch.
Deine Pranks gehen ein bisschen weit, Florentin. Wir alle lieben deinen Channel und es fing lustig an, irgendwie mit den Oreo-Pranks, aber dass du jetzt Städte den Strom wegnehmen willst. Ja, aber das ist doch auch super gefährlich. Stell dir mal vor, die Karten, die Leitungen, dann liegen beide Enten auf dem Boden und dann kommt da so eine Ente vorbei und dann, also das ist halt richtig gefährlich, weil dann hast du alles im Boden? Die Ente? Ja, oder irgendwas anderes und dann ist der Strom im Boden, dann kriegst du den nicht mehr raus. Das ist die Erde. So gut kenne ich mich nicht aus, ich weiß nur. Es gibt auch die Frage, man darf ja keinen Föhn in die Badewanne fallen lassen, aber angenommen, ich bin in der Ostsee. Und dann fällt mir der Föhn in die Ostsee. Alle Füsse tot. Ja, also... Das wird halt dann gleichmäßig aufgeteilt, das ist halt so ein leichtes Kribbeln. Und dann der Thunfisch so... Aber der Wal... Aber was mich fasziniert, ist ja, das deutsche Stromnetz oder Stromnetze generell, da ist ja der Verbrauch genauso hoch wie die Produktion von Strom. Nee. Doch. Deutschland erzeugt mehr Strom. Naja, aber jetzt in so, also von der Spannung halt her. Also wenn du jetzt... Mir gefällt deine Argumentation. Moment. Mir gefällt es total, wie du dich immer rausschlawien hast aus, immer na ja, und dann kommt Bullshit. Na ja, aber sagen wir mal die Spannung. Wenn du den Lichtschalter anmachst, muss irgendein Kraftwerk ein bisschen mehr Strom erzeugen. Nee, weil statistisch gesehen, immer wenn ich den Lichtschalter anmache, der Günther den Lichtschalter ausmacht. Ja, aber rein von der Idee her, wenn du den Lichtschalter anmachst, muss insgesamt mehr Strom erzeugt werden. Das muss immer ausgeglichen sein. Ich glaube, genau, ja. Das ist total abgefahren, dass es wirklich eine absolute Harmonie ist. Aber wird jetzt nicht einfach mehr Strom produziert und das Problem gibt es einfach nicht? Nee, ich glaube, du kannst wirklich immer nur, weil es ändert sich dann in der Frequenz. Du hast ja, ich glaube, 60 Hertz und wenn zu viel Strom gebraucht wird, wird die Frequenz langsamer. Und wenn zu viel Strom da ist, wird sie schneller, also im 0,00 irgendwas. Du kannst ja nicht einfach aufhören, außer in grossen Batterien von Elon Musk. Die können aufhören, ja. Die hat grosse Batterien, da wird Strom drin gespeichert, aber ich glaube, sonst kann er nicht gespeichert werden. Ja, aber der fließt ja. Bin mir nicht sicher. Bist er rein? Aber in Batterien fließt der Strom oder ist der nicht einfach eingefroren? Nee, da ist nichts. Fließt nicht. Das ist halt wie ein Stein auf einer Leiter. Aber wo du gerade sagst... Der kann runterfallen, muss aber nicht. Sowas wie GTA, nur mit besserer Ursache-Wirkung-Mechanik, wäre geil. Angenommen, du kannst durch GTA laufen, nimmst dann diese Bazooka und feuerst mal auf so einen Strommast und dann mal gucken, was passiert. Weißt du, wenn das alles physisch, von der Physik her, richtig wäre, dann wäre doch richtig cool. Dann könnte man so gute Sachen ausprobieren. Was passiert? Nur mal auf Scheiß, wenn ich jetzt eine Kettensäge nehme und einfach mal diese Strommast durchsäge. Was gucken, was passiert. Und dann mal gucken, was passiert. Und dann macht man das mal und dann gucken wir mal, ob Los Banditos im Hintergrund dann tatsächlich Strom noch hat. Ei, ei, ei! Come on ich dachte auch immer, ich dachte sehr lange... Schüttel die Füsse. Schüttel deine Schuhe.
Nee, schüttel deine Stiefel.
Ja.
Your Boots.
Your booty is made for walking.
That's just what it does.
Kann es sein, dass es diese Trash-Urlaubshits nicht mehr gibt?
Nee, in deiner Blase gibt es viel zu viele.
Ach ja, das kann man ja.
Klar, Apresci.
Blasen sind geil.
Blasen sind mega. Vor zehn Jahren gab's keine Blase und du musstest halt dieses
Hören, dieses hier von DJ Burbo mit diesem Hund, mit diesem Chihuahua.
Ich hab jetzt am Wochenende.
Warte, wie war das nochmal?
Chihuahua.
Genau, äh Chihuahua.
Das ist auf sich eingefallen.
Kein Text, wir mussten uns keinen Text merken, nicht meine Melodie. Wie war's nochmal? Chihuahua. Ach ja, genau das war's, was man instinktiv eh als erstes macht. Wie lief dieses Pitch-Meeting ab? Herr Bobo, schön, dass Sie da sind. Es gibt bei Liedern keine Pitch. Schön, dass Sie da sind, Herr Bobo. Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben den neuen Sommer-Hit 2001. Ach ja, war das heute der Termin für den? Genau, Sie sollten heute die Partitur abgeben. Sie haben ja schon gesagt, Sie haben sich auf A-Dur eigentlich geeinigt. Da waren wir Ihnen ein bisschen skeptisch. Aber wir haben jetzt sogar gesagt, Bobo, das Genie, da kommt schon was bei Rom, nicht wahr? Äh, Chihuahua. Toll. DJ, tolles Video von Jenny Nicholson, unserer beiden Lieblings-Star-Wars-Bloggerin. Und zwar gibt es ja in dem Film The Last Jedi, den du ja so gut fandest. Ich freue mich immer noch, ongoing Streits mit sehr vielen in der Internet-Community. Deswegen, lass es mal, warum muss man immer einer Meinung sein? Ne, sag ich ja gar nicht, darum geht es mir nicht. Es gibt eine Figur, die heißt DJ. Und Jenny Nicholson hat rausgefunden, dass es irgendwo mal einen Roboter gab, und zwar gab es irgendwo mal, glaube ich, eine Achterbahn, eine Star Wars Achterbahn. Der hat so ins DJ wegen Don't Join. So, eine Achterbahn, und die wurde gefahren von einem Roboter, der aber nicht offiziell in der Star Wars Welt war. Und der hieß Rex. So, und diese Achterbahn wurde von einem Roboter gefahren. Aber irgendwann hatten die keinen Bock mehr auf diesen Roboter und auf diese Achterbahn und wurde es irgendwie umgebaut. Aber den Rex gab es noch als Erinnerung. Aber dann war er DJ Rex und hat einen Platten aufgelegt. Und da hat Schlussfolger Jenny Nicholson, dass es in Star Wars den Begriff DJ als Discjockey gibt. Das heißt, die Frage ist, warum wurde DJ, als er sich als DJ vorgestellt hat, nicht kurz gefragt. Sorry, was meinst du, DJ was? Hast du auch einen Song von der Kantine-Band? Das hätte noch reingemusst dann wäre der Film perfekt gewesen an meiner Stelle. Und anscheinend gibt es ja, er hat Schwächen. Es gibt Falken in Star Wars, bei Millennium Falke. Ja, das ist ein Problem. Es gibt Falken. Wo gibt es Falken? Es gibt Wings. Gibt's auch Tauben? Gibt's auch Rettich? Nee, ich glaub genau, Lauch? Wo ist die Grenze, frage ich doch. Es gibt auch die Erde. Da hat wirklich auch Jedipedia auf Spaß zu machen. Jedipedia, es macht sehr viel Spaß, man kann sich einlesen und plötzlich wird das Universum noch grösser und man denkt, wow, das ist wirklich eine Welt, die es da draußen gibt. Und dann gibt es die Erde wie, vor allem wortwörtlich der erste Satz der Saga in einer weit, weit entfernten Galaxis, weit, weit entfernten Galaxis. Ja. Warum schreibt man Erde in den Wikipedia-Eintrag? Aber vor allem weit entfernt wovon? Von uns. Wie, von uns? Dann muss es die Erde ja geben. In dem Moment, in dem du sagst weit entfernt. Ja, klar, in dem Universum, aber in der Galaxie nicht. Und da macht die PDA einen Fehler. Apropos fremde Welten, wir haben ein Mail bekommen. Frauen. Ja genau, zum Thema Heiratsantrag. Wir haben in der letzten Folge die Frage gestellt, wie es aussieht mit dem gescheiterten Heiratsantrag. Und wir haben gefragt, ob ihr Erfahrung habt. Habt ihr schon mal jemanden einen Heiratsantrag gemacht und hat die Person gesagt, ich habe keinen Bock. Und darauf hat einer unserer Hörer geantwortet, und zwar der Marvin. Und der schreibt, ich selbst habe noch keinen Heiratsantrag gemacht, aber ein guter Freund von mir. Der war damals immer ein bisschen eifersüchtig, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das unbedingt vorlesen soll, aber ein guter Freund von mir hat seiner damaligen Freundin einen Heiratsantrag gemacht, direkt als sie 16 geworden ist. Sie ist 16 geworden. Ja, aber das ist doch fake. Am 18. Geburtstag? Sie war völlig perplex. Was? Du liest doch vor. Frag mir keine Frage. Sie war völlig perplex und hat aus Hilflosigkeit erst mal Ja gesagt. Nach ein bis zwei Wochen hat sie ihn dann aber abgeschossen und wollte ihn nie wieder sehen. Die hatte ich ganz anders in Erinnerung, die Mail. Viel lustiger. Anscheinend hat sie aus Verlegenheit Ja gesagt. Das ist auch blöd. Kann man das offiziell zurücknehmen? Oder ist das wie so eine Art Kaufvertrag quasi? Also das habe ich auch gelernt, wenn ich sage, ich hätte gerne zwei Brötchen und die gibt mir zwei Laugenbrötchen, die Bäckerin,
dann hat sie den Kaufvertrag missachtet. Und dann kann ich theoretisch, wenn ich merke, sie hat mir zwei Laugenbrötchen gegeben, den Kaufvertrag anfechten. Notfalls mit einem Anwalt. Mit einem Schwert. Oder mit einem Schwert. Und das ist doch genauso. Also, ich weiss nicht, ob es bei ... Aber die Ehe streng genommen, also die Ehe kann mir ja auch gewisse steuerliche Vorteile bringen. Also in dem Moment, wo ich sage, ich bin auf das Geld angewiesen und sagst du was, wie willst du mich heiraten, ich habe es gerade nötig, die Frau sagt aus dem Schlussreflex, äh, ja, dann... Gildet! Gildet das doch, oder nicht? Es gildet eigentlich. Es gildet ist eigentlich eine supergute rechtliche Grundlage. Ich glaube, du musst aber schreien, gildet. Es gildet. Ich glaube, rechtlich ist Hochzeit erst ab der Hochzeit, Ehe erst ab der Hochzeit relevant, oder? Alles, was davor passiert? Aber davor gibt es ja eine mündliche Zusage quasi. Ja. Ehe Zettel, hier unterschreiben. Ja, oder Ehevertrag kommt auch dann erst zum Tragen, ne? Ich habe keine Ahnung, Ich weiß nicht, was das ist. Im Ehevertrag kannst du, falls es zu einer Scheidung kommt, oder kann man sogar schon bei der Ehe Dinge verlangen. Ich habe irgendwann gelesen, dass sich jemand Sex in den Heiratsvertrag gedealt hat. Mindestens zweimal in der Woche Sex. Dann kommt die Sexpolizei und was passiert dann? Ja, was passiert dann? Das frage ich dich. Oder hat er ein Anrecht darauf, fremd zu gehen, oder wie meint er das? Ne, ich glaube, ein Anrecht bei der Frau auf zweimal Sex in der Woche. Und dann kannst du ihn ja klar auch noch so Unterklauseln reinhandeln lassen. Wie lange hat er nachgedacht, bis er sich auf zweimal die Woche festgelegt hat? Weil wenn du eine Zahl festlegst, dann kannst du ja auch sagen... Er denkt natürlich auch daran, dass er bei ihm ja auch nicht... Irgendwann ist ja auch Schluss. Also irgendwann kann er das ja auch nicht mehr einhalten. Oh, ich wäre gerne alt. Rente. Ich würde gerne jetzt aufhören zu altern. So Spaziergänge, wirklich? Ja. Nee. Wirklich? Ich habe bei dir das Gefühl, du reifst mit jedem Jahr immer weiter. Ich habe das Gefühl, du bist noch nicht an deinem Potential angelangt. Nee, das nicht. Gerade als du würde ich auf jeden Fall altern wollen. Weg aus diesem, raus aus diesem widerlichen Gefäß eines Körpers. Juhu! Wir sind im alten, guter Arbeit Originals Autorenraum heute. Wir wurden nämlich vertrieben aus unserem normalen Raum. Es sieht nicht mehr aus wie ein Autorenraum.
Früher muss man sich vorstellen, Kohlerdosen lagen in der Ecke.
Das war einfach ein Raum, den hat man uns gegeben.
Der hatte weisse Wände, einen Tisch in der Mitte
und Stühle.
Und dann meine Frage, was braucht man denn
auch noch mehr? Gar nichts.
Eben. Wir haben Whiteboards an der Wand.
Ja, und jetzt kommen wir hier rein
und es ist hier ein Dokumentarteam,
was hauptsächlich aus Frauen besteht. Und der Raum ist wunderschön. Wunderschön. Viele Farben. Die Führung der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kürze und der Kumentarteam, was hauptsächlich aus Frauen besteht und der Raum ist wunderschön. Wunderschön. Die Wand ist bemalt. Da hängt ein Bild an der Wand, ein Gemälde, Blumen sind hier, Pflanzen. Da sind sehr viele Pflanzen. Unfassbar. Bügel. Aber das verstehe ich nicht. Bügel, man kann einfach über den Stuhl leger seine Lücke hängen. Er ist erwachsen geworden, der Raum, ne? Von dem grössten albernen Bullshit-Projekt jetzt zu dem erwachsensten Projekt. Wir wollen ja irgendwann noch mal eine gute Arbeit Originals Throwback-Folge machen. Ja, einmal eine Folge, wo wir alles klären, was passiert ist. Weil die Fragen von euch häufen sich ja, wir kommen ja nicht mehr raus. Aber das frage ich mich auch, war das bei Seinfeld auch? Haben die erst die ganzen Backstage-Sachen aufgenommen und Audiekommentar zu jeder Folge oder gab es erst die Nachfrage dazu oder haben die gesagt, ja, es wird schon mal irgendwann irgendwen interessieren?
Ja, zum DVD-Release, glaube ich, machen die das oft dann nochmal.
Ich will aber auch, ich will, dass die Leute dafür interessieren, was ein Backstage zu lief, aber das ist, glaube ich, wirklich ein Missverständnis, was seit Jahren in der Medienbranche vorherrscht. Leute interessieren sich einfach nicht dafür, was so war. Ja, und es passieren auch nicht so viele interessante Dinge eigentlich, oder? Ein paar Skandalchen, aber ich glaube, die nehmen wir auch mehr als Skandalchen wahr. Die waren ja gar nicht so groß. Ja, aber jeder hat Skandal. Die Sache mit dem Wasserautomaten. Auch jeder, der in der Versicherung arbeitet, hat auch einen Skandal. Da gibt es dann auch irgendwie einen Kollegen, der dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwas umwirft oder so. Und dann sagt man, jetzt ist es umgefallen und so. Und das sind Geschichten, die schreibt das Leben. Also das kannst du dir auch nicht ausdenken. Deswegen glaube ich, ist es echt wichtig, dass wir da auch dranbleiben. Ich hab mal mit jemandem von der AXA, wo du das gerade sagst, mir hat mal jemand abends bei so einer Bierlaune erzählt, dass er bei der AXA arbeitet und da sehr viel falsch läuft.
Nee, ergo, ergo. Mir hat mal jemand abends bei so einer Bierlaune erzählt, dass er bei der AXA arbeitet und da sehr viel falsch läuft.
Ne, Ergo, Ergo-Versicherung.
Und da läuft der... Ergo gehe ich zu einer anderen Versicherung.
Und da lief sehr viel falsch und der arbeitet da in der IT-Branche und sagt, die Daten, sicher, nein.
Das hat er auf gar keine Frage hin gesagt, sondern einfach so aus sich heraus.
Das war seine Story des Abends, kennt man ja. Jeder hat ja so eine Story für die Party, mit der man rumläuft. Hast du das? Ich habe immer eine Story. Ich überlege mir mal eine Go-To-Story. Falls irgendwann mal eine peinliche Stille auf einer Party abends entsteht, habe ich immer eine Go-To-Story. Jetzt würde mich aber natürlich brennend interessieren, was ist deine Go-To-Story? Das kann ich nicht sagen. Warum? Weil du jetzt mit allen Hörern nicht mehr Smalltalk-Fühlen hast? Ja, genau. Dann ist das die Go-to-Story gestorben. Aber was ist das denn für eine geniale Story, die du zu jeder Zeit anwenden kannst? Nein, nein, das ist meistens eine Story. Meistens ändert sie sich ja von Monat zu Monat mal, was man gerade so erlebt hat. Also eine Go-to-Story wäre zum Beispiel, wenn ich, keine Ahnung, was da gerade passiert ist, wenn ich umgezogen bin, ist das meine Go-to-Story. Es ist jetzt nicht, oder wenn an dem Leben, du meinst Leben. Wenn an dem Tag
ich eine, ähm, vom
Geldautomaten beschissen wurde, weil
und der mir kein Geld gegeben hat, dann wäre das meine Go-to-Story.
Halt immer was an dem Tag so passiert ist.
Aber das überlege ich mir halt vorher, das ist der weirte Part.
Nicht die Story ist der weirte Part. Dann erzähl mal
die Go-to-Story von vor einem Jahr.
Die ist ja verjährt jetzt.
Hau mal eine Go-to, ich will mal so,
wie ist es so mit Stefan Tietze, außerhalb des Podcast-Studios zu kommunizieren?
Man trifft ihn so auf der Straße.
Ey, waren wir nicht zusammen damals irgendwie in diesem Comedy-Autorenkurs oder sowas?
Ja, genau.
Aber jetzt habe ich diese Zimmerpflanze mir heute gekauft.
Okay.
Und die sieht fantastisch aus.
Warum erzählst du mir das?
Und dann habe ich die einfach auf so eine Fensterbank gestellt.
Das interessiert mich nicht.
Aber darunter ist auch so eine Heizung.
Ich muss aus jetzt.
Und deswegen, ganz lustig, ist die zu heiß geworden wohl.
Und ist auch sehr relativ schnell eingegangen.
Wir sehen uns.
Oh, ist schon grün.
Ciao.
How to small talk.
Ist grün so eine positive Farbe wegen Pflanzen, weil Pflanzen so unaufdringlich sind?
Hoffnung, sagt man.
Aber gibt es in allen Kulturen, grün ist gut und rot ist schlecht? Oder rot ist, Achtung, so eine Tomate. Das wäre auch lustig, wenn die Briten statt links zu fahren einfach rot und grün bei Ampeln getauscht hätten. Ja, oder wenn die die Hüte an den Füssen trägen. Trügen. Fucking Konjunktiv macht mein Geh kaputt. Bevor ich zu meiner Ergo-Story weiterkomme, wir haben gelernt, dass tatsächlich der Futur 2 tatsächlich mit Konjunktiv gebildet werden kann und das Verb werden ist in Zukunft 2. Plonti und Stefan werden einen Podcast aufgenommen haben. Also, wir werden keine Ahnung von Grammatik gehabt haben, wir würden keine Ahnung von Grammatik gehabt haben.
In diesem Beispiel, in diesem rein fiktionalen Beispiel, würden wir eine Folge aufgenommen haben, hätten dann Wasser geholt, wären wir mit dem Fahrrad gefahren, zum Beispiel. Das wäre so eine Verkettung. Aber wir würden eine Folge aufgenommen haben, nachdem wir mit dem Fahrrad zum Kiosk gefahren sind. Warum haben wir 135 Folgen gebraucht, um endlich mal die deutsche Sprache zu verstehen? Jeden, der die deutsche Sprache lernen will, ich schlage ab einfach, das kannst du vergessen. Ebenfalls die große Storyline von diesem Typen an dem Abend war halt seine Ergo-Geschichte und der hat bei der Ergo gearbeitet und hat mir einfach gesagt, dass die Daten dort nicht sicher sind. Und es ist mir gerade erst eingefallen, wo man sagt, das ist eigentlich ein Riesenskandal. Und das ist genau dieses Missverständnis, das man hat, dass die eigenen Dinge, die man beruflich erlebt, andere interessieren. Der hat mir wahrscheinlich den größten Insider erzählt. Er war quasi der Riesen-Whistleblower, Ergo-Gate. Es hätte ein Riesending werden können, und ich habe es ignoriert. Ja, weil er weiss, dass du nicht die Möglichkeit hast, da was umzusetzen. Aber gerade ich, der in den Medien arbeitet. Informationen haben ja nur einen Wert auch gegenüber anderen Leuten. Das sagt es jetzt nicht irgendwie der Datenschutzbehörde, aber dein Kumpel schon. Ja, aber im Neomagazin, wo du auch teilweise mal Beiträge hast, die Leute an den Prang herstellen. Warte mal, ganz kurz. eine Sache will ich, es gibt nämlich eine Website, es gibt ja immer mal
wieder so Account-Leaks,
wo irgendeine Website gehackt wird
und dann werden alle Accounts
geplündert von den Hackern. Und so wie ich
das verstehe, sind diese Accounts
dann im Darknet verfügbar.
Also da ist dann, Account heißt,
E-Mail-Adresse und Passwort.
Die ist dann verfügbar und eigentlich
kann dann jeder Hacker mit denen machen, was er will. Zum Beispiel versuchen, sich bei Facebook einzuloggen damit. Und da gibt's Es ist ein, das wir jetzt nicht mehr als die, die wir jetzt nicht mehr als die, die wir jetzt nicht mehr als die, die wir Also anscheinend scannen die dann diese Listen im Darknet oder was auch immer und finden raus, ob deine E-Mail-Adresse dabei ist. Ich habe mir meine Adresse eingeben,
meine E-Mail-Adresse war aus sechs verschiedenen
Quellen. Was?
Sechs verschiedene Quellen.
Einmal Adobe war dabei,
wurde anscheinend gehackt, Dropbox war
dabei, dann Eight Tracks
war auch dabei, MySpace,
halt viele so alte
Wo kann man das schauen? Wie heißt die Seite?
Ich weiß nicht, aber ich glaube, es heißt
Did I get pwned?
Also P-W-N-O-D.
P-W-N-E-D.
Guck mal, ob das funktioniert.
Ja, aber ohne O, aber P-W-N-E-D.
Genau, Did I get pwned?
So, jetzt bin ich mal sehr gespannt.
Und von denen bestimmt.
Lustig, dass wäre, wenn
Have I been pwned auch dazugehört. Ja. Good News. Nein, gar nichts. Das ist im fucking Ernst. Warum bin ich der Einzige? Nee, nichts. Meine andere, meine alte vielleicht. Audiva auf jeden Fall. Ja, die ist locker. Adobe und Dropbox. Alter. Aber die benutze ich auch Gott sei Dank nicht mehr. Ich dachte so, oh ja, krass, was für eine Erkenntnis, jeder hat was dabei, aber anscheinend bin ich wirklich der Einzige. Sowohl Passwort als also beides muss dazu gehören. Ja, davon gehe ich aus, sonst ist es ja ein uninteressanter Hack, weil was bringt dir denn die E-Mail-Adresse? Naja, für Spam, wenn die die für Spam weiter benutzen. E-Mail-Adressen sind wert, klar E-Mail-Adressen haben Geld. Ja, aber dann kriegst du, das ist ja kein Skandal.
So, die E-Mail-Adressen kannst du ja auch einfach kaufen, oder nicht?
Da kannst du ja irgendwo, ich glaube schon, dass das mit
Passwort dabei ist, wenn die wirklich so
sich da so irgendwo reinhacken, diese
verrückten Wiesel, diese
Internetwiesel, die da so umkrabbeln.
Lustigerweise, die unseriöse Familien-
E-Mail-Adresse wurde auch nicht gehackt.
Also tatsächlich nur Scheiße.
Nur meine. Nur meine
E-Mail-Adresse von sechs
verschiedenen Outlets einfach. Das ist wirklich
Ich bin der Fall. Eine Mailadresse wurde auch nicht gehackt. Also tatsächlich nur Scheiße und deine. Nur meine Mailadresse von sechs verschiedenen Outlets einfach. Das ist wirklich spannend. Übrigens, ich habe herausgefunden, wie ich noch mehr meine Genen machen kann. Wo wir gerade dabei sind, Daten, Genen, einfach die Daten in die Menge zu schmeißen. Um ganz ehrlich zu sein, nach der vorletzten Folge finde ich Genen ein bisschen zum Gähnen. Alter. Alter. Wir holen die Gag-Pite raus. Ich bin tatsächlich männlich. Schüttel deine Chromosome. Und zwar kann man, das habe ich nämlich nicht gewusst, weil man kann nämlich bei 23andMe, wo ich das eingereicht habe, in Deutschland kriegt man da keine Health Reports. Genau. Weil das verboten ist in Deutschland. Die können dir nichts über die Gesundheit sagen. Prozentsatz, wie viel du Alzheimer bekommst. Genau, wie viel Prozent du Alzheimer bekommst, Krebs, all deine Risks zum Beispiel, genau, oder auch was du intellektuell vielleicht durch deine Gene mitbekommen hast. Kriegst du nicht mit. Stattdessen bekommst du aber umsonst dank des Gesetzgebers deinen ganzen Gensatz als RTF-Datei. What? Und den kannst du dann, der sieht weird aus, und den kannst du dann bei anderen Seiten hochladen, die als Free Service anbieten, deine Gene auszuwerten. Nein. Ich natürlich meine RTF-Datei genommen. Du bist so dumm, das willst du doch nicht wissen, wenn da entsteht 80% Alzheimer. So, tatsächlich habe ich das auch nachher erst bereut. Ich habe aber meinen Gegensatz hochgeladen, anonym ist das dann, die Seite speichert das auch nicht, du kriegst einfach eine Datei ausgeworfen und hier sehe ich jetzt genau, was meine Risiken sind.
Oh nein, du bist so doof, warum machst du das? Es ist wirklich ganz doll schlimm. Und jetzt habe ich sogar zwei Kopien von Alzheimer, also bad, hier steht bad. Nein, wie bad, was heißt bad, gibt es very bad? Nee, es gibt nur bad und es gibt nur good und es gibt neutral. Aber Alzheimer ist bei mir bad, an increased risk of Alzheimer's disease. Leute, diesen Podcast wird es vielleicht dann irgendwann nicht mehr geben, weil ich Alzheimer habe. Du hast mir das alles in der letzten Folge schon erzählt. Ich bin resistant to HIV. Wie resistant? Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das geht. Wie ein Hai oder was? Ja, ich bin, hier steht, ich bin HIV-resistent. Wie resistent? Hier steht, resistant to HIV. You have the donor genotype described at bla bla bla, da ist link, also known as CCR5-Delta-32. Consider becoming a marrow donor, nee. Aber tatsächlich. Moment, aber heisst es, du bist resistent, heisst ja nicht immun. Resistent heisst nur ein bisschen widerstandsfähiger. Genau. Also ich glaube, vielleicht kriege ich einfach seltener HIV. Oder was he heißt genau resistent? Ich glaube, resistent ist schon gut. Aber resistent ist nicht dasselbe wie immun. Immun ist wirklich, da geht nichts. Aber resistent ist ein bisschen weniger, wahrscheinlich. Ja, ich glaube, Resistenz heißt, ja. Resistenz? Aber naja, gut. Klingt gut. Also HIV ist ja... Unempfindlichkeit des Organismus gegenüber schädlichen Äusseren Einwirkungen. Ja, aber unempfindlich ist dasselbe wie ... Wir hätten mal ein bisschen konkreter mit der Sprache. Das ist doch alles ... Gibt es noch eine Chance, dass du betroffen bist oder nicht, wenn du unempfindlich bist? Ja, ich glaube doch. Du bist halt nicht empfindlich, aber ... Also dann unglaublich, aber das wusste ich ja schon, unglaublich hohes Krebsrisiko. Easy, das wusste ich schon. Jeder Krebs oder gibt es ein paar Favoriten? Breast Cancer vor allem, Zervikal, was ist Zervikal? Irgendwas mit Hals. Naja, also Krebs auf jeden Fall. So, und jetzt tatsächlich habe ich ein Gen. Und das ist sehr selten. Ja. Und das sagt aus, ach hier auch noch, Autismus wahrscheinlich. Tatsächlich? Bisschen autistisch sind wir beide wahrscheinlich.
Und dann ist aber das interessanteste Gen ist, man kann nämlich hier auch gucken, was es mit dem Mind macht, was man für Gene hat, die den Intellekt beeinflussen usw. Und da habe ich tatsächlich nur grüne Gen, also Good Genes, nichts, was irgendwie rot ist. Und eines hilft quasi, also Menschen, die dieses Gen haben in der Ausprägung, in dieser Variation, sind sehr empathisch, haben ein Auge für Details und sind stressresistent. Okay, super. Ja, und da dachte ich wirklich, das finde ich ganz, ganz toll. Wahrscheinlich kann man deswegen auch auf einer Bühne stehen, zum Beispiel. Aber wie testet man, ob ein Mensch empathisch ist oder nicht? Wie sieht so ein Empathietest aus? Das sind zehn Leute. Jetzt musst du fragen, wer von denen ist empathisch und wer nicht. Also zum Beispiel stellst du zehn Leute mit einer Nummer vor sich hin und dann fragst du, wer von denen ist gerade glücklich? Und dann, der lacht, fällt mir sofort auf, weil Menschen, die lachen... Naja, aber das... Du kannst mich jetzt verwachen. Wenn ich Menschen sehe, die auf der Straße lachen, weiß ich sofort, der ist wahrscheinlich glücklich. Das kann ich. Das ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen objektiver. Die zeigen dir wahrscheinlich ein Bild, wie ein Hund geschlagen wird und dann messen die, wie stark deine Rezeptoren für Schmerz ausschlagen oder so ein Kram wahrscheinlich. Oder sowas in der Richtung. Aber ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum ich bei Filmen so oft weine. Und dann halt viel Type-2-Diabetes und so, aber na ja. Aber alles in allem ... Der Mensch ist ja schon ausgewogen, oder? Also für jede Stärke, die du hast, hast du auch eine Schwäche. Ich sehe es ein bisschen so wie bei Sims. Wo man am Anfang kann halt so Charakterpunkte verteilen und irgendwann ist es halt vorbei. Und dann kriegst du halt die Schwächen. Ja, ja, ja. Aber jeder hat nur so und so viele Punkte. Es ist niemand bevorzugt. Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, wir verfransen gerade ein bisschen so Rassentheorien und so. Ich glaube, es ist alles ziemlich gefährlich, wo wir da gerade sind. Aber finde ich gut, ich finde es echt, also, ich finde es, ich meine, es ist jetzt nichts Konkretes mit Good, Bad und Neutral, aber ich finde es schon mutig, dass du das machst. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das wissen wollen würde. Weil ich meine, ändert das jetzt irgendwas in deinem Leben? Crohn's Disease auch. Sowas wie Alzheimer kann man ja auch irgendwie dann jetzt irgendwie, kannst du dann viele Weintrauben essen oder so ein Kram, dass du halt dann oder da gibt es ja irgendwie so ernährungsmäßig, kann man da ein bisschen was machen? Ja, kann man auch. Und was machen? Hast du dich da informiert? Dann musst du dann tatsächlich Geld bezahlen. Also da gibt es so ein paar, aber auch ganz gute Seiten, die dir sagen, ach genau, und ich bin, das passt an mir auch dazu, wie man sich bewegen sollte am besten, also wie die Muskelgruppen, die man hat, am besten eingesetzt werden. Meine Muskelgruppen sind nicht für Ausdauer geeignet, hätte ich mir schon fast gedacht. Ich bin likely, more likely a Sprinter. Also meine Muskeln sind eher für die kurze Anstrengung gemacht. Was ich auch gemerkt habe beim Tennisspielen. Also als ich vom Fussball zum Tennis gegangen bin, habe ich plötzlich gemerkt, dass ich wesentlich besser bin in dieser Sportart. Ich habe mich damals immer als unsportlich bezeichnet, aber im Tennis war ich dann irgendwann noch ganz gut. Wahrscheinlich, weil einfach der Sport besser für meine Muskelgruppen geeignet war. Ich konnte wesentlich länger spielen, manchmal auch als andere, weil man einfach diese kurze Anspannung hat und dann auch schnell wieder eine Erlösung. Oder weil du gegen Kleinkinder gespielt hast. Oder weil ich einfach, genau, weil ich in einer Frauengruppe war mit zwölfjährigen. Das kann auch daran gelingen haben. Aber ja, sehr interessant, ich kann nur jedem raten, die Gene auf unseriösen Seite im Internet hochzuladen. Ich glaube, was soll da schon schief gehen? Wie gross ist die Datei, die deinen Gensatz enthält? 16,8 Megabyte. Und es ist eine RTF-Datei. 16 Megabyte? Aber das ist nur Text wirklich, nur so Code? Es ist nur Text, es ist wirklich nur Text, es ist kein Code, da ist ja auch so drin am Anfang, hi, this file contains raw genotype data. Also in jedem Fitzel von deinem Körper sind 16 Megabyte Speicherplatz. Also auch in so einem kleinen Bluttropfen kann man ja DNA-Analyse machen. Genau. Und da sind immer 16 Megabyte drin. Aber das haben wir ja eigentlich leidbekommen. Das ist schon krass. Wir haben dann 20.000 Informationen. Wie viel, dann hat ja dein ganzer Körper insgesamt Millionen Hexobyte. Und man muss sagen, Gene sind schlecht formatiert. Also ab und zu rutscht dieses Einrückzeichen rein, wo man sich fragt, wo kommt das denn her? Und habe ich dieses Einrück-Smiley und die lustigen Tränen-Emojis, habe ich die auch in meinem Blut? Ihr könnt mir
Freundschaftsanfragen schicken und dann kann man die Gene vergleichen.
Dann könnt ihr gleich wissen,
ob ihr euch mögt. Gibt es bestimmt
so Dating-Portale, wo du deinen
DNA-Satz einschickst, die dann einfach
ganz... Ist das nicht in Island auch so,
weil Island so klein ist,
dass die Dating-App berücksichtigt,
ob man Gene teilt?
Ja, stimmt. Das ist ja anstrengend. Muss du aufs Alter achten und auch noch auf die Gene. Am I right? Ja. Kannst du da jetzt die Datei ändern? Kannst du da so ein bisschen was anderes? Ein bisschen weniger polnisch. 100% Deutsch, Herr Tietzer. Das haben wir noch nie gesehen. Tja. Neulich habe ich Leuten davon erzählt und ich habe ein bisschen zu stolz gesagt, dass ich hundert Prozent Europäer bin. Ich bin hundert Prozent Europäer, ohne Scheiss, hundert Prozent, alle so, yo, alles klar, komm ein bisschen runter. Ohne Scheiss, Alter, hundert Prozent Europäer. Aber glaubst du, jeder findet schon sein eigenes Land am geilsten? Ich habe ja am Wochenende wieder den Eurovision Song Contest geguckt. Und ich habe mich schon gefreut, dass wir Vierter geworden sind. Ich habe keine Erklärung dafür, warum das so ist. Und eine Studie hat herausgefunden, glaube ich, in den New York Times, jetzt auch für den Eurovision Song Contest, dass es glücklicher macht, wenn man sein Land guckt. Wenn man sein Land sieht, wie es performt, ist man automatisch glücklicher. Das ist einfach wissenschaftlich bewiesen. Hast du das auch, wenn du ein schönes Deutschlandspiel guckst? Ja, schon, irgendwie so ganz irrational dann doch. Aber ich weiß nicht, es ist auch nur wegen der, also WM ist für mich einfach die Zeit des Jahres, da gehe ich steil. Und das ist für mich wirklich alles. Vielleicht ist es wegen Hunger Games so, weil früher, da haben wir ja dann die deutsche Nationalmannschaft auf WM geschickt und da mussten die halt einfach, wenn die gewonnen haben, hat man mehr Rationen bekommen als Deutschland. War das so früher? Ja, da hat man mehr Essen bekommen. Und vielleicht ist es deswegen immer noch so, weil die Hunger Games immer noch in uns drin sind. Kann man denen nicht ein bisschen positiveren Namen geben? Funny, Fun Games oder Fun Day. Ja, oder Satt Games, also das Gegenteil von Hunger. Food Day, Food Games. Hat ein Amerikaner ein Wort für Satt? Nourished. Nourished, mhm. Vier Joghuretten hat Stefan in sich reingedrückt in der Zeit jetzt. Könnt ihr mal rechnen, was das für ein Tagesverbrauchter Yoguretten ist? Kennst du das, wenn du das Gefühl hast, du hast die Süssigkeit vergessen die letzten Jahre, und dann entdeckst du sie wieder und denkst dir bitte, was habe ich denn die letzten Jahre verpasst? Mella. Nie gehört. Mello? Mello? Mella. Mella? Mellä, Mellä, Mellam, Mella. Mello, all diese Scheiss Karamellnummer. Mella oder Riesen. Wann hast du das letzte Mal Riesen gegessen? Nogga. Nogga. Nogga. Nee, und jetzt habe ich Joghurette wieder entdeckt. Und irrational, weil ich mag Erdbeeren gar nicht so gern. Ich mache immer um Erdbeereisen großen Schlenker, aber Joghurette finde ich das ganz tontergebracht. Das ist verfassbar. Stefan! Was? Warum sagst du das so, als ob du das schon abmoderieren willst? War es das schon? Ich wünsche einen schönen Abend. Wie? Jetzt einfach so, oder weil wir Schluss machen müssen? Nee, war jetzt auch, muss man sagen, sehr nah beieinander. Wir haben die letzte Folge erst gestern aufgenommen. Gefühlt. Ja, stimmt. Weil wir jetzt mal an die Anfang der Woche müssen. Ist ja nicht so schlimm. Stefan, ich wünsche dir eine fantastische Woche. Du hast ja viel vor. Ich wünsche auch dir eine fantastische Woche. Wird ich in Urlaub? Nicht wirklich. Die Tour geht weiter. Wir haben jetzt noch Berlin und Hamburg vor uns. Also wer noch keine Karten hat, kriegt auch keine Karten mehr.
Aber ansonsten, glaube ich, haben wir uns eine Menge zu erzählen nächste Woche.
Ich freue mich sehr drauf.
Ich freue mich auch sehr drauf.
Ich bin ganz gespannt, was du gemacht hast.
Und wünsche euch eine schöne Woche.
Und ich würde sagen, Leute.
Leute, macht's gut und wir heben ab.
Vielen Dank an Andre für das Intro.
Yes, ich habe dran gedacht.
Sauer, danke schön.
Vielen Dank an alle, die weiterhin einschicken. Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Wir heben ab und sagen Tschau.